on a day-to-day basis now I'm at Arizona
State University where the Institute is
based I normally teach a course in the
spring I'm involved with a number of my
colleagues in writing scientific papers
and still traveling to Ethiopia to the
place where Lucy was found in 1974 all
those years ago so we're still searching
for fossil remains I travelled quite a
bit to a lecture at colleges and
universities and continued to write and
publish books
well I think when when one sees a brand
new discovery for example in the pages
of a National Geographic magazine or
whatever they think you just kind of
travel out there and look around and run
into one of these bones and it's almost
by luck that one finds these things but
we apply a pretty strategic plan to
surveying and completely scouring an
area we will map out an area on aerial
photographs and systematically work
through the various grid system that we
set up spend three or four days in an
area the size of a new york city block
for example with maybe five or six
people and the only way to find a fossil
is to look and look and look and look
and hope that the light is right that
you're concentrating on a particular
spot and once you find something you
then kneel down have a close look at it
before you even pick it up make a
photograph map it exactly now of course
we can use GPS units and in the case of
a fossil that's been broken you try to
keep people out of the area so that
there's no damage done to any of the
bone fragments and you set up a very
micro grid system so that you map every
piece and number it as you pick it up
and photograph it and bag it and bring
it back to the research camp where we
identify it catalog it and actually
photograph it in more detail
well there's nothing really that helps
us search for fossils we can use
satellite imagery to eliminate areas
that where there are volcanic rocks for
example fossils are best preserved in
sedimentary rocks like sands and silts
and things like that and they leave a
particular signature in these aerial
photographs so we know where not to go
and we know where we might have a
possibility so that finding fossils
themselves still involves all of the
ground survey going out making
preliminary surveys in a vehicle finding
a place that has fossils then
concentrating on that area and searching
day in and day out and then ultimately
determining whether or not we should do
any excavation sometimes we actually do
excavation in the case of the Lucy
skeleton that I found in 74 most of her
was exposed on the surface she had been
eroded out by the the rainstorms in the
area but other places we've had to do
significant excavation